foreign
[Music]
this is the skull of one of the most
famous of dinosaurs Tyrannosaurus Rex
it's also one of the most intensively
studied species yet even so new
discoveries are still being made about
this formidable predator
oh
continues to Fascinate us is how good
they were at hunting
factors in their success were their
senses
so how powerful were their eyes
they're hearing
when we want to understand a little bit
about dinosaur senses
it's really really difficult
we don't have any of the sense organs
preserved but we can get some Clues to
things like eyesight just from the
outside of the skulls
we can look at the shape of the eye
sockets this gives us some Clues as to
the size of the eyeball and also the
directions in which the animal were
looking
g-rexifies faced forwards
evidence for binocular vision
and they were huge the size of
grapefruits
[Music]
fields of vision of its two eyes overlap
substantially giving it very good depth
perception which would have made it a
very effective predator
the modern world
but they don't just rely on sight
combined with their acute senses of
smell and hearing they contract prey
from miles away
together
could T-Rex do the same
[Music]
new medical scanning techniques provide
evidence that it could
CT scanning is something that's really
revolutionized our work in paleontology
and it's giving us insights that were
simply impossible to gain from looking
at the bones themselves
now reveal Secrets hidden inside T-Rex's
brain
what we can see is that there are key
areas that relate to different senses
like eyesight and smell
these are located in specific lobes of
the brain
the bigger those lobes are the better
the eyesight or the better the sense of
smell
large Optical olfactory lobes suggest an
excellent sense of sight and smell
but it doesn't end there
the inner ear is adapted to pick up low
frequencies
an advantage when detecting prey over
long distances
really impressive senses would have
combined to allow them to hone in on
prey very quickly and very accurately
now there's an exciting new Theory
night vision cameras have revealed many
modern Predators like lions can use
their highly developed senses to hunt at
night
perhaps T-Rex could do this too
until relatively recently it was assumed
that dinosaurs were mostly animals of
the daytime
but if we actually look at the behavior
of living animals there's no reason to
think this is true
Predators can use the cover of Darkness
to Ambush other animals much more easily
it's likely T-Rex would have made the
most of such an advantage
they're very very powerful sense of
sight and smell would have allowed them
to hunt prey very very effectively in
low light conditions and perhaps even at
night
modern research techniques mean
scientists continue to make new and
surprising discoveries not only about
T-Rexes
but many of the other dinosaurs that
lived on our prehistotic planet
[Music]
thank you